Religion is increasingly suppressed
among educated people.
It's not suppressed politically or
legally,
uh,
but my students say,
yeah,
I'll as I students in colleges across
the country,
um,
have no concept of what the Bible is or
what's in it.
Think of it as a toxic book.
Know nothing about Christianity,
less about Judaism.
Um,
so at the same time when the threats to
human dignity,
dignity and integrity are going to be
ramped up to extraordinary levels of
stress where we most need wisdom and
moral seriousness.
We're seeing wisdom and moral
seriousness come under attack.
And often from the same people who want
to do the genetic engineering is
crusading.
Crusading.
Atheism is sort of a clause today is
popular.
I don't want to say among scientists,
I mean as to do general.
It isn't so,
but there are certainly a prominent
people in the scientific community are
prominent people who were religious Jews
or Christians in the scientific
community.
But there are also prominent people,
um,
who have taken their atheism to the
public successfully,
who are crusading atheist,
who preach atheism,
atheism in an aggressive way.
Um,
as a consequence of the science,
they play on people's weakness in
ignorance.
So far as most people don't take the
trouble to learn science.
It's easy for a scientist to saying,
I'm smarter than you are because I know
it and you don't know.
I understand the genome and you don't.
I understand the physics.
I can do hard calculus problems and not
just twelfth grade level one.
So you can see how much smarter I am
than than,
than you are.
And what I tell you there,
there are no moral absolutes and
religion is trash.
And furthermore,
we ought to go ahead with human cloning.
We should go ahead with genetic
engineering and implantables sorts,
which will smudge line between human and
machine.
We're getting into a,
a moral conflict of interest,
which is tremendously dangerous.
I,
I don't think we will succumb.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
human beings have faced hard challenges.
The Second World War was,
is difficult to crisis as mankind ever
will face a,
I'm 50 million people died.
I'm a humanity.
Teetered on the edge.
I'm a state.
Paganism was preached aggressively by
Hitler.
I Germany,
which despised Christianity as much as I
hated Jews.
It didn't hate Christians as people,
but it hated Christianity.
Um,
uh,
the Japanese empire,
which was a w which revived stay
paganism in preference to the more
sophisticated religion of Buddhism and
Christianity that had been popular in
Japan.
Stalinist Russia,
which was an aggressively pagan nations,
suppressed Christianity.
That was a crisis of enormous crisis.
We rose to the occasion.
We defeated it.
It damaged us.
We still bear the scars.
Um,
I think we're going to face a crisis in
the coming century.
It will be different in character.
He's never the same.
We never see the same crisis twice.
Um,
I,
I know we have the moral,
a strength to rise to the occasion,
and I hope and pray that we do in
practice.